dominic bouchard n'avait jamais entendu
parler du cancer des ovaires lorsqu'elle
a reçu son diagnostic en ou 2015
ces symptômes semblait peu alarmant un
espèce de fatigue oui mais surtout un et
todd de gonflement de difficultés à
digérer
après plusieurs tests elle apprend
qu'elle est atteinte d'un cancer des
ovaires de stade avancé
même s'il est peu répandu le cancer des
ovaires est souvent surnommé la maladie
silencieuse du pourquoi parce que c'est
un cancer qui dans les phases précoces
donne des symptômes plutôt généraux ont
dit nous autres noms spécifiques ce à
dire que ça a l'air d'un peu n'importe
quoi
cette maladie touche surtout des femmes
ménopausées de 50 ans et plus selon la
société canadienne du cancer 3000 femmes
auront reçu un diagnostic de cancer des
ovaires en 2019
comparativement à près de 27000 patiente
pour le cancer du sein et je le connais
c'est tellement beau tellement pas
j'avais je me suis même d'avoir un
participant d'un dut avoir été sollicité
les patients doivent souvent voir
plusieurs médecins avant d'obtenir leur
diagnostic et plusieurs mois s'écoulent
on n'a pas de bons tests de dépistage
pour détecter précocement le cancer
parce que bien sûr quand il est détecté
précocément pas des traitements sont
plus efficaces
il est aux dirigeants sont meilleures
les spécialistes opte donc pour la
prévention plutôt que d'avoir une
négation des trompes
il propose aux femmes de les enlever
complètement on pense que ceux de cette
façon l'eau dans peut-être quinze vingt
ans on devrait voir une réduction du
nombre de cancers ou variés marie plan
espère que les médecins de famille
soulève cette possibilité plus
rapidement de son côté dominique
bouchard espère aussi informer les
femmes
en mai dernier la organisé un concert
bénéfice au profit de la fondation du
chuq québec pour la recherche sur le
cancer des ovaires
en plus de recevoir une magnifique
prestation ses 2 200 personnes en ont
pas entendu parler une façon de redonner
aux suivants pour dominer le bouchard
qui se porte maintenant beaucoup mieux
ici qu'à me sanson radio canada québec